[Music]
my o my guruvar babes is it Wednesday
already
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
your Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode three 11 chapter 46 the red
Dalia
now today I'll be bringing you the
inside scoop straight from Cole Sprouse
and we're gonna get our prompter moving
a little bit first awesome
today I'll be bringing you the inside
scoop straight from Cole Sprouse talking
all about this week's new are themed
episode hence my look woody verbs sing
Plus as always I'll be dropping my three
clues and answering your live questions
so start sending them my way but first
let's take a look back at some of your
best hisses kisses comments and theories
from episode 310 chapter 45 the stranger
now first up Carmen Carmen commented
hisses to Jughead for letting sweet
Penang stay after killing someone but
kicking Shoni out for stealing an egg
kisses to FP for being sheriff and a
Fred for defending his son okay I think
we can all agree that Shoni was not just
kicked out of the serpents because of
the egg but yeah I will agree that sweet
pea and fangs straight up killing
someone was weird
next up na'vi 16 posted hisses to how
Alice is changing from the badass mom we
all love to a complete stranger and
unlikable character this one hit me
right in the heart I love Alice and I
personally think that she and FP and
Fred are the very best of the Riverdale
parents but it's hard to love you when
you act like a brainwashed psychopath
Alice meanwhile Neela Desai's said why
do the writers give out tallboy every
time as a false alarm honestly I think
it's become a habit beau killer of Jason
blossom beau black hood and now probably
so gargoyle King agreed I adore the
Riverdale writers and I'm sure it must
be extremely difficult to write these
episodes but the overuse tallboy twist
has become very frustrating
and Tom underscore 10 wrote his sister
Veronica for not exiting the SATs for
Archie he needed help and she wasn't
willing to give it to him no sorry Tom
but I'm definitely going to disagree
with you there it's not Veronica's job
to chase after a team boy having a
temper tantrum she needs to put her own
priorities like her education first and
I was actually very happy to see that
she didn't leave the room listen up
ladies no boy is worth sacrificing your
education no matter what now moving on
from my mini rant at Darius Morro for
tweeted me and said ever notice how all
the people at the farm are women maybe
mmm that maybe this has something to do
with the seizures and why they've been
all women so far I love this theory and
I'd never even noticed that so great job
but speaking of theories about Riverdale
women
Erica leezar commented Hermione
definitely shot Hyrum now if you notice
he always calls her Mia Moore and when
he was on the phone he actually said my
love all all betty was actually on the
phone with his mistress and Hermione
shot him Erica I love that thought in
fact I did another poll on ETS community
tab about Hiram's mystery shooter and
asked you all to vote on who you think
pulled the trigger nearly 10,000 of you
river babes voted and here are the
results
now 67% of you voted Hermione while 13%
voted for Hiram's mistress seven percent
said that Archie totally did it while
13% of you are convinced that it was
someone else entirely
with names like Fred Andrews Reggie and
even Edgar ever never being tossed into
the mix now I love how closely you River
babes pay attention but let's see but
let's all shift our attention to the
promo for episode 311 you've got to deal
with your demons hello
you sure your husband excuse me you're
exploiting other women I do a job I get
paid for it
you're a part of it Barry it's a salmon
it's like she's committed the perfect
murder no rest for the wicked not in a
wicked town
are you intrigued or confused
how about country well I actually don't
know how you're feeling but I do know
that I'm feeling generous so here are
your three clues about chapter 46 the
red Dalia number one one of season
three's biggest questions will finally
be answered what the question is which
one number two a fan favorite couple
will finally share a scene together that
their interaction is more professional
and personal and number three one
character is crime crocodile tears while
another has been plotting their revenge
for years now before we start our live
Q&A portion of today's preview aka my
favorite part I have an exclusive
interview that I'd like to show you
first now this week's special new are
themed episode of Riverdale is bringing
us a look at sheriff FP and also guest
star Kelly Ripa and I just so happened
to ask Cole Sprouse about all of these
things so take a look at what he told me
episode was interesting because the
episode changed quite a bit from the
first draft that the actors had received
to the finalized version but I think
where we ended up is like a very
Riverdale version of under war but
originally they were planning to do
black and white I think and a lot of
super cool ideas I don't know how that
episode's gonna end up I know that joke
heads narration runs quite a bit more as
a current throughout the episode which I
think feels very more in general no
one's innocent in crime town we pick up
on some themes like the femme fatale and
those kind of iconic tropes from the
noir genre so I think it's gonna be a
cool episode and we also got Kelly Ripa
on the episode which is great when you
found out that they were bringing in
Kelly to play Hiram's mistress I loved
it it's it's this show so well I also
had the pleasure of being in the major
scene with her which was great so I got
to act I saw her for the whole time
which was fantastic
she's pint-sized but she's a firecracker
oh yeah that's great
yeah it's very funny cuz she had this
this little pistol you know in a very
Riverdale fashion as usual I don't even
know how to hold this thing who the hell
are you and how do you know my name
we've always seen that jug is such a
good investigator it runs in the Jones
family blood because we're gonna CFP
sitting on that sheriff hat it's cool
it's kind of foreshadowing too I think
it's a nice little way to play a kind of
Batman and Robin dynamic between skeet
and I or like a sort of deputy role for
Jughead too which is a lot of fun but it
also you know it also presents itself as
something dubious in that now serpents
can kind of get their way with the law
in a capacity that they probably didn't
have the agency to do before so who
knows how loyal skeet is gonna end up
sticking to the badge you know I adore
cold and I adore all of you river babes
so let's dive into your live comments
and see what you have to say and by the
way thank you guys for sticking through
me this is showing that's really live
today so I got a little tongue-tied
we're all good let's move on
Emily Lawson says will jelly bean and
Gladys be back soon jelly jelly and
Betty need to meet every week I'm gonna
say the same thing that is the combo
that I need to see the most and I can
reveal that yes they will be back in
just a few episodes I'm not gonna tell
you which one but I'm sure Roberto has
already admitted it because he's
revealing all the spoilers lately let's
see oh Emily Lawson also said is the
goal to get the entire consuelo spam on
riverdale before they kill off Hyrum it
seems like it we've already had Mark
Consuelos his son on the show Kelly's
been on the show and I believe his
daughter was also a stand-in for one
episode she was an extra in the
background so I think they're already
all on so if they want to kill off Hyrum
now I'd be fine with that I'm so excited
that so many of you are already tuning
in right now let's see osc1 one two one
says I'm so excited
school is canceled so I finally get to
watch this live so excited and ready hi
and for all of you guys who are dealing
with the polar vortex right now please
stay warm but I'm glad you're inside
watching Sweetwater secrets
neela says barchi is best as a
friendship I think
okay and Queen Susie says bar cheese
federer's friends a lot of people are
given bug head and Shoni love today
Graham divergent says do you think that
Penelope blossom took the missing River
vixens to work in her brothel I don't
think that she did that but that's an
amazing theory where are the missing
River vixx's I love how they just show
up every once in a while and they always
seem to kind of change but that's
amazing that I wouldn't be surprised
that can help we blossom did that I
don't think she did but great Theory Ava
xoxo says are there any Griffins and
gargoyles in this episode no which is
exciting this is a very different
episode it is our new or themed episode
and as you just heard Cole explained
they wanted to do this episode quite a
few different ways originally they were
talking about doing it all in black and
white which I don't know if any of you
guys are pretty little liars fans I was
and I loved their entire black and white
know our episode I think they did such
an amazing job this episode is not going
to be nearly to that same level there's
only a few newer elements
it's kind of like Riverdale with a hint
of noir but we'll get more into that on
our after-show
yeah it's definitely an interesting
episode I'll say that for now
Ashleigh see does anyone else notice
that at the end of the last episode
Reggie had a it's a boy a balloon I saw
in the comments last week that so many
of you guys took this as a as a hint
that Veronica is pregnant no knowing
Reggie who's um maybe not the brightest
bulb in the box that was the only
balloon that stood in for Hiram Hiram is
a boy it's a boy I think that's one he
got pretty sure they don't sell sorry
that your dad got shot balloons I
haven't seen them in any of the
pharmacies that I've been in but hey
this is Riverdale they would make a
killing if they started selling balloons
like that
so someone get in on that idea Alicia
says I kind of want FP to let the
serpents do some gang stuff now that
he's sheriff it feels like they're
laying low right now and then needs more
badass serpents moments
yes I so need some badass serpent
moments because honestly I don't know
what the serpents are anymore they're
supposed to be a gang I'm not for
illegal activity and apparently neither
is Jughead because he keeps doing the
squash on it but then they go ahead and
like kill people like tallboy which that
death to me still was really bizarre he
walks in and he's just shot on the floor
if it's gonna be like that just at least
show the shooting really quickly I was
just really abrupt not a fan um
Timbaland says once again hisses to
Veronica giving everyone the cold
shoulder yes I was not a fan of the way
that Veronica treated Reggie and Archie
in last week's episode and I went into
that in my rant of hisses I think that
Veronica's just got a lot on her plate
right now I think that they're trying to
give her a lot to deal with and it just
isn't coming off it's not painting her
in the best light shall I say they all
want to know about phallus my phallus
fans hi I'm right there with you I want
it just as much as you do um I will say
you will get a phallus scene tonight
that helped it's not what we want
but they're together we're gonna take
what we can get at this point
Christy Hall where is the Sunnyside
trailer park supposed to be in North
Side or South Side I thought the
serpents were kicked out of the
Southside but they're all still living
in the trailer park off the top of my
head I don't quite know the geography of
Riverdale and I think I would have to
ask Roberto about that maybe he can draw
me a map and I'll share it with you guys
but I do feel like the answer to that
lies within the Midnight Club episode
because FP was lying about going to a
different school but he's really living
in the trailer park so I'm assuming that
the trailer park is on the south side
but then he remember he was like
pretending to be a jock and like changed
his address so that he could go to
Riverdale high so I'm gonna go out on a
limb here and say that the sunny is
whatever trailer park is in the south
side Kirk at says I still think
Veronica's pregnant and needs to get an
abortion because I refuse to have a
hashtag veggie baby
oh that got dark real quick I do not
think that we were going to be having a
pregnancy line on Riverdale anytime soon
which I hope not because that is played
out and I don't need to see that um show
me show me show me show me show knee so
many show any comments I'm right there
with you guys
I miss my show knee showing you will be
in tonight's episode
but much like with phallus it's very
quick not sure if you'll be pleased but
they are there Tony does have a really
sweet line where she comes to Cheryl's
defense on something let's see Caroline
are says Roberto is hinting that someone
was going to die in this episode can you
say anything on that topic by the way
love sweetwater Caroline are thank you I
love you for watching right now I love
all you River babes Roberto has been
teasing so much right now if Roberto
said that someone might do is hinting
that someone is going to die considering
we have a death in like every single
episode now sure why not just I'm sure
someone will die it keeps happening in
fact they keep doing it twice everyone's
dying twice that's gonna be in my hisses
and kisses rant after this episode twice
everything's twice okay Amelia says
Hermione let someone shoot Hyrum you
guys she would shoot him at least four
times just like small fry oh the son of
Papa poutine okay this is a great
comment and you know Hermione very well
I'm not going to say anything about the
Hyrum shooting but the fact that you
know who my name is shooting style is
amazing and will come in handy later
Ruby Harper do Shoni actually got any
scenes together or apart
I miss Madeline and Vanessa I miss
Madeline and Vanessa too that's why I'm
so excited for next week's bizarro Dale
episode of Riverdale because we are
going to finally get to see some serious
screen time for Josie Kevin Reggie
we've seen a lot of Reggie but
specifically Tony and Sheryl I'm so
excited for this episode I'll have so
much inside scoop from Ashley Marie as
well as Vanessa Morgan talking about
this episode
I cannot wait I need more of them it's
kind of silly that we have to have an
episode that just focuses on them there
should be more of a balance as we move
forward also did you guys notice it in
last week's episode Kevin was in it the
entire time but didn't even say a word
that bothered me okay moving on Kathy
says Mei Chen recently spilled that they
casted the actor for Edgar can you tell
us anything about when he will appear
finally I knew that they were gonna be
casting him I did not know that they
actually cast him so I will reach out to
the Riverdale publicist and see if I can
get that casting news for you guys I
don't think they're doing any stunt
casting which is where they cast an
actor that we all know about but I do
know that they were looking for someone
with kind eyes so kind what makes eyes
kind I don't know ooh we're getting so
many yes they all want to see Edgar I
want to see Edgar too I hope his kind
eyes are buggy eyes like it like Evelyn
Lucas gee why does Veronica get upset
when she thinks Archie shot Hiram
wouldn't she be happy for him if he did
that I don't get it I don't get it
Veronica much either these days but
let's be real who do you really want
your boyfriend to shoot your father
cuz as we've seen quite a bit throughout
this season Barranca very much despises
her father but then as soon as he does
like the smallest nice thing she's a
thinking my dad isn't such a bad guy
you can't entirely hate your father
maybe
Veronica can't entirely hate Hiram I do
so there's that unique Karen I like that
Handel named unique Karen I don't know
how unique it is my mom's name is Karen
too but unique Karen says I can't
believe I'm saying this but I miss chick
I'd takes chicks sketchy actions rather
than the gargoyles Twiggy hands I think
that you should tune in to the after
show with me tomorrow because I have
exclusive quotes from certain Riverdale
star talking bout chick and it all ties
together great job miss Chandler bong
best handle name yet ah actually it
would be miss Channing
cooller bong for the die-hard friends up
friends fans out there miss Chandler
bong said last season midge died in the
musical episode and as Roberto said
someone will die who do you think that
will be in this season's musical episode
dun dun dun
I hadn't even thought about who will die
in the musical episode let's see I feel
like so I haven't seen the musical
episode I haven't seen up that far so
this is actually me guessing blind I
don't know I'm gonna say that right now
so last year was midge and they had
introduced her quite a bit and then they
killed her off so I think they really
introduced her just to kill her off so
if we're gonna do that the same Mabley
maybe it's Evelyn ever never because she
was just introduced this year we were
getting to know her a little bit maybe
it would be here I would be bummed by
that I'd be okay if moose died sorry
Mebane fan fans you know that I think
that Kevin deserves so much more Venus
says so a while ago in one of the first
episodes I saw in the Cooper household a
newspaper with what appeared to be
chicks mugshot any chance he'll be
appearing again go back to my earlier
answer about chick and watch tomorrow's
after-show but I did not see that on the
newspaper that would be such a lovely
little Easter Egg if you guys kind of
want to go back and find that for me and
that'd be great
sorry my hair keeps doing this thing
where I get so excited to talk to you
guys that it gets bigger and bigger so
my amazing director is just telling you
to smooth it out gem Bree says kisses to
Reggie for not giving up on Veronica
after she tried to shut down their
relationship and showed up to the
hospital I mean yes that was very nice
effect he should go to the hospital I
don't I don't know I'm like I said I
still need to figure out more from them
we keep seeing them share more scenes
together and it's mostly just brought by
being like Reggie I have a mission for
you he's like okay and then they do it
and then by the end of it I'm still just
like alright not sure how I feel about
you so if something actually needs to
happen
Jenna bug head needs to come back we
need to see them give kiss pecs and
cuddles but I also want them to
investigate more than just more cute
it's not a 30-second moment I agree I'm
a smug head however one of the things
that I like so much about Betty and
Jughead the season is that they're super
strong
why don't you rather have a strong
couple with like not as many moments
than what we had last year we're like
every other episode they were like
having a big emotional breakup and then
getting back together and like yes we
had more of those romantic scenes but we
also had to watch them have a lot of
heartbreaking scenes I don't know what
do you bug head fans think do you prefer
that we're not seeing as much romantic
Ness but that they are in a good place
or would you rather have the big
back-and-forth thing that like Veronica
and Archie are going through right now
I'm kind of fine with it we're gonna
take just a couple more comments convene
Kevin said Veronica just used her
father's shooting as an excuse to break
up with Archie because she was feeling
guilty for cheating on him and I guess
she had already fallen for Reggie
technically she did not cheat on Archie
they were broken up he broke up with her
on the phone call that's not cheating so
we're not gonna label Veronica a cheater
Reggie's nice to look at he was around
all the time you do you boo Alda says
Charles Melton says on insta that Josie
and Archie are gonna be a thing and
veggie will be a thing oh okay yeah so
I've been seeing this a lot online what
do you guys think of the possibility of
Archie and Josie becoming a romantic
pairing here are my thoughts we will be
seeing their friendship kind of rekindle
again but why can't people just be
friends I love their friendship that's
what I would like to see I would like to
see Archie and Josie cuz she puts him in
hers in his place
she's so sassy and great and I love for
the pieces do I want Josie to have a
emotional love interest yes I do but I
just want the new friends I don't know
if I see them romantically but maybe you
guys do tell me just a few more comments
Addison says Penelope is the real
gargoyle King because she's never there
and Claudius was killed by Hermione and
the ladies are taking over I think it is
a time for ladies on Riverdale and it's
about damn time I think it's time for
for the lady moms to rise up and and I'm
all here for it if it means
room goes away I have nothing against
Mark Consuelos I think he's a phenomenal
actor I'm just ready to see more than
just like him being like me huh and
really upset okay
just a couple more Holly Thompson I've
heard Ashley is leaving Riverdale and is
going to the Riverdale spin-off to
resume her role as Josie is this true I
have not heard that if Ashley were to
leave Riverdale to go to the new
Riverdale spin-off which is about a
different Archie comics character Katie
Keene and it's going to be like a
musical dramedy set in New York that
sounds like a perfect place for Josie to
go and to actually get some screen time
so if that does work out I consider
Ashley Marie to be one of the talent
most talented people on that cast
I think she's sensational and as a human
she is a delight so if she has the
opportunity to go to a show where the
spotlight is shout like shining on her
more yes go for it I think that would be
sensational well I miss her own
Riverdale yes but all my best ava exo
OMG everyone is talking about our chose
e the only reason why I don't approve is
cuz Archie has already kissed five
people because five that that seems a
little low that seems really five this
season or five in total I do have I do
have some quotes on that but I will
break out to you guys but a lot of you
guys are loving and shipping our Josie
interesting well I don't know
Addison Penelope is the real Oh we read
that one one more okay
tatianna says I feel like Edgar is going
to be very charming and possibly steal
Alice from F P I would be really upset
by that I just saw that I'm sure she's
taken with Edgar and things looked like
the Sun rises and sets in his eyes in
his kind eyes but I would not be okay
with that
I need I need more phallus before I lose
them all so so many of you guys have
been commenting about barchi how much
you love Barney how much you want to see
Betty and Archie get together so
barchi fans listen up you all have been
commenting I hear you I see your
comments so in honor of next week's
bizarro Dale episode of Riverdale I'm
spilling the barchi tea now tune in to
next wednesday's live preview show
because I'm going to finally be gifting
you with my interviews with Kay Chapa
and Lily Reinhart where I asked them
both about the possibility of Betty and
Archie sharing a romantic future and I
think their answers will surprise you
but for now River babes do me a favor
and give this video a like and then hit
subscribe so you never miss an episode
of sweet water secrets then head on down
to the comments to see if you can crack
my three clues do you think Hermione
shot Hiram's what do you think is the
red Dahlia which couple do you think
deserves more screen time Joanie and
phallus and share your thoughts with me
below tune in after you've watched
episode 311 chapter 46 the red Dahlia
for more exclusive interviews with your
favorite Riverdale stars now kiss you
later River babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]